Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome to 'Vacate the Room.'
Now this is a Virtual Reality experience!
It's supposed to be like one of the 'Escape Rooms'
That I've played numerous times
that are usually made in Flash,
but this one's made in Unity.
Haboink!
(angrily) Ha-haboink!
There we go.
Oh...
WAEohh,
Man,
Wow, I am cramped in this room!
How did I get in here?
And why can't I see anything?
Why am I trapped?
Freedom please!
Okay?
Woah, what is that up there?
Can I grab this?
Woah, what is this?
It looks like a fuse, but I'm not 100% sure.
So this is supposed to be... exactly like a room escape.
Oh, good!
I need this!
Oh, shit!
How am I supposed to maneuver this?
No power?
Try this.
Oh, okay, but there's a lock over there.
Okay, so this is obviously a fuse or
something of the like,
So, I'm gonna put this down there for a second.
Don't roll off! No, No. Ah!
Damn it!
God damn it.
Stop. Go-
Gi-gimme.
Thank you.
Okay.
Now you don't roll... stay right there.
Okay, it's gotten...
Nooo... NOOOOO!!!
Okay, you stay there.
Alright... hang on
I got to get this flashlight a little better on my-my other hand.
OH!!!
Cold, delicious, refreshing Choke!
I love a good choke first thing in the morning!
Hello.
Woah.
Hi.
Are you watching me?
Better not be, I'm watching this guy.
I don't know who you is
but you might be the game developers so...
Hello.
Shit.
I made it phase through the floor!
Okay
Anything on the back of this?
Anything on the front of this?
No?
But this is really cool,
'cause I gotta like explore everything.
Oh, hi!
Mow The Lawn, Man!
An awesome movie about enjoying Virtual Reality
while working in the garden.
Phteven King?!
Wow! Oh, Hello. Wow, hang on.
Bup, pahow. Oh shit...
Whoooaa! Hey, buddy. Alright, get that outta here.
Hup, catch...
Hup, catch.
Haboink! Whoa, man that's so weird!
Virtual Reality to the max, bruh!
Ok! So this goes on what...?
There's a number panel over there- Whoa, hey!
How's it going buddy? Do I need to scan that QR Code?
I don't think I can do that "in" this game.
Alright, this goes somewhere...Where the fuck does this go?
Crumpled pieces of paper. Nothing of note.
Uhhh, nothing there.
Som-Oooh here's a piece of paper.
Alright, "All this stuff! Books, movies and even music ...
... I guess I used them as some kind of escape ..."
Page number 2.
Ah! Here we go.
Oh, wait.
It's the same thing on either side
Okay, nevermind. But that's note number one...
...Or note number two
Goddamn it, gimme
Okay. So I'll set you over here. Here's note number one.
Okay. "I'm still here! Even if I came here on my own ...
... escape seems not to be impossible anymore."
Oh! "Not to be 'possible' anymore."
Who was I to think that I was reading words correctly?
Hi!
"From the maker of 'Loud Mountains'
Stiller Hill"
Hup!
Huphup!
There we go! Ah!
"Stiller Hill no one will listen" Okay.
What about you?
Ooooh The Wrong
Ringo! Haha Ringo. Of course!
My favorite movie!
Ringo!
Hi! Okay.
So I got that.
I've got the fuse. Can I turn this on anyway?
What's in here?
Nothing...
What about down here? AH! There we go. I found you!
Okay! I got this too.
Now I got two of these things.
But I still need to figure out how to...
...put them in there. 'Cause I need a key for that, I believe.
Let me just... right there.
AH! There you are!
Hello!
Can I get you?
Thank you! Okay.
So I got another one of these. Boink!
Leave those there.
Okay. Something to do with this.
HEY! FUCK YOU! I'm just an old man!
Tryna hobble my way back through time...
...to a point where I gave a fuck. Bam!
Anything behind the monitor?
Oooooh hello! Found you!
Okay. Handy that.
I've got these. Get outta here!
Get that 'Choke' outta here.
'Kay that did...
...that did nothing 'cause I still have no power!
Man, I'm lost.
What is that?
Oh!
Oh, there's something back there!
*gasp*
It's a code! "14504"
Okay! 14504.
1-4-5-0-4
No? Nothing? Maybe on this one.
'Kay. 1-4-5-0-4
I don't feel like I'm pressing 'em.
Oh! Wait. What's in the...what's in here?
Hang on. There's something in here.
What's in here?
Ooooh there's something down here. Hang on.
Trash
But this. What is this?
Ooooooh. That don't look good! I can't read that?
It's numbers...
Is it numbers?
Is that numbers?
I can't quite tell what that is.
What is that?
Ehhhh it's just- Nah it's letters. It's a love letter
to my uh...my lovely wife.
Oh! Hello!
How long have you been there?
I don't recall you being there but I found you.
Ok...
Well I found that one which might mean that I've missed other things.
What could I have possibly missed?
I've been pretty thorough.
I don't think there is anything down there.
Unless there is then I'm an idoit.
OH! THERE!
Oh! I haven't looked there!?
I can't believe that!
I must've looked there!
I gotta spin my way to victory 'cause I got tangled.
AAARRRGGGHHH!
I hope I'm spinning the right way...
Oh well whatever...
Sheit!
Okay. I'll deal with it.
Doink!
Okay!
Chuchunk!
Aright!
Wow! That is a lot more colors than I thought there was gonna be.
But I think I've got 'em all.
Boink!
Okay. So that got blue light over there.
And then I got the rest of 'em over here.
Get outta the way mouse.
I've got a mystery to solve!
Baboink!
Oh! We're doing so good!
Haaboink!
Okay. On a roll baby!
Haboink!
Mkay.
And last one which amazingly I've found 'em all already.
Ha-BAM!
Oh! We got power! Okay. That makes sense because I wasn't able to do anything before.
Okay. Lets see if the computer will turn on. Hello!
"What's going on? It seems as if I'm locked in this Room!
How will I get out? Maybe I left a clue sumewhere ...
... hope I did not discard it ..."
Well, that would be horribly stupid wouldn't it?
Can I use this at all?
No...
"Hope I did not discard it ..." You talkin' about this freak o' nature here?
I guess I'm done with this.
Alright. It was nice knowin' ya.
Thank you!
Have a good one. Okay.
14504. So 1-4-5-0-4
Yes! Okay!
Gimme this!
Now I need you now!
♫ Now I need you now! ♫
Wow.. Okay...
"How to escape:
Find the Keys
Find the Fuses
Find the Letters
Climb out?" Question mark.
Okay! And it's a drawing of what I can only assume is freedom.
Alright! Here we go!
Haboink! Haboink!
What do we got?
Oooooh! Hello!
Hang on! I need this!
Whoa...
Alright. What do we got?
Whoa! That looks uncomfortable and cramped!
Oh boy! Hi! How's it goin'?
I don't know where I am in my room but it probably doesn't look good...
Okay. And another note over here.
Ah! I can't grab that one it's to far floo- below the floor!
I'll just read it from here.
"All the time ... ... wherever I did not want to see anybody ...
Now I want to see somebody ...
but I don't think I can!"
Well, that's to bad for you, douche!
You made your choice now sleep in your bed.
Alright. I think this gotta go here? Woo!
And then...
Haboink!
Yeah! What did that do?
Wha-What did that do?
I don't know what that do...
What did that do?
Oh?
No?
Well. Oh! Here we go!
Oooooh! Is this a thing?
Doesn't look like a thing...
But this might be a thing that I need to do to...
Okay...
Hang on...
Wait...
No?
Nothin' there.
Wait is there somethin' there?
Oooooh! Wait a minute!
Wait a minute! Wait a minute! There's something here!
Safe Code 2....784
Whoa!
That is hidden!
2-7-8-4?
No. That must not have been it.
Uh...2874 probably.
AAHH!
Okay! Alright! Okay!
Ooooh! Is this who I am?
Who is I?
"Exit Pass?"
Nice!
(inaudable) pass?
Alright.
"I have to stop hiding myself! The real life is goin on outside!
I have to get out!"
I couldn't agree more!
I couldn't agree more, man!
Okay...So...
Boop! Whoa! Hey! What the fuck are you doin'?
Ooooooh! That's where the handle comes in! Okay. Hang on.
Wait... Oh! Goddammit with this
"I did it! I found my way out of here! If I want to escape the room
I just have to take off the VR-Headset!"
Wow! Isn't that handy-dandy!
Or!
Eh.
Sheit!
Ugh.
Huh Eh.....Tits!
Be Freeee!
Uh...Oh hey!
Huh Eh!
My God! It's like magic!
Take my 'Choke'!
Oh shit!
Nehaha
Okay...But I think that is actually it. So...
That is...Whoa! Hey! Hi guys!
That is VR Escape the Room.
That was actually a really cool experience.
I had a lot of fun with that.
It was amazing 'cause I had to, like, literally crawl
and actually physically explore my environment
and that was part of the game. That was, like, the first
game that has made physical interaction in the environment
the actual gameplay.
Which is amazing because it actually take advantage of what the VIVE is about.
So, that was really cool but I wanna know what you think of it.
Let me know in the coments down below.
And thank you everybody so much for watching!
And, as always, I will see you in the next video!
Bye bye!
OH! YES!
Oh! You like that? *smooch*
How 'bout a little bit of that
on the tip of your giant nose?
Oh! Float like a butterfly. Kiss like a bee!
*smooch*